The actors in this tv show
have been shielded from the press,
but their characters have lived their
lives on the tv screen and social media.
Tonight two of the main characters
speak publicly for the first time.
Please welcome Tarjei Sandvik Moe
and Josefine Pettersen.
Welcome.
Please sit.
We started the show by talking to Laleh,
and she said she wanted to be herself.
And this is the first time
you will be yourselves
and not Isak or Nora,
the characters the Norwegian
and Danish audience know you as.
How does that feel?
It's a little bit scary.
I love being an actor
and portray other people.
But we can try this.
-Are you ok?
-Yes.
It's nice that people
can get to know us as well.
A lot of people have been wondering
what we're like.
My daughter came to me and said:
"How do they know what life is like
for my friends and I?"
That made me very curious
and I wanted to watch all of it.
You see what it's like to be young.
A lot of the response
is that it feels very real.
What's the secret?
-It's Julie Andem.
-The director.
And screenwriter.
They've done a lot of research
and have had chats with 16 year olds
about what life is like.
They studied them, in a way.
That's how they did it.
She also spoke to us a lot.
She'll ask me: "How does this work?"
And I'll tell her.
I'm cheating. Because I'm portraying
a sophomore at Nissen high school,
and that's what I am in real life.
So I know what it's like to be young.
-You're 17. You're a little bit older.
-20.
-You portray a younger girl.
-A 16 year old.
Has that been hard?
Not really.
16 doesn't feel like that long ago.
Jeg remember starting high school.
I remember what it was like.
It's a little bit different now that I'm
20. You feel a lot more grown up.
Do people still think you're 16?
In Norway people only know you as Nora.
A lot of people think I'm Nora.
I was out in Trondheim. You had to
be 20 to get in, and I am 20.
Så I wanted to go out
and have a good time with two friends.
I was sitting there drinking a beer,
and one of the security staff came up
to me and said: "Come with me."
I just... Ok.
I thought he was
going to give me free alcohol.
I said: "Fine, I'm coming."
"Can you show me some ID?"
"Yes."
"This isn't you."
I said: "I know.
I look very young in that photo."
"I was 15."
"I know it's not you."
"Ok. What's the..."
He said: "I've talked to a lot of people
tonight. I know this ID is fake."
"You're 16 years old
and your name is Nora."
I got really stressed.
"I'm an actress in a tv show
where I play Nora who's 16."
He said: "Ok. Yeah, sure."
He didn't believe me.
He said: "We need to call the police.
Come with me."
He called the cops and I had to
answer questions about myself.
Tell them where I've lived,
tell them about my parents.
Finally I said:
"Can't you just google me?"
It turned out ok. I got a humble apology.
-Did you get a free beer?
-No.
I got my beer back. It was on the floor.
You're 17 and you've never had beer
or any other alcohol.
-Of course not.